שזירה קוונטית מאפשרת לחלקיקים להיות מקושרים בלי קשר למרחק ביניהם זה כל כך לא אינטואיטיבי
שאפילו Einstein לא חשב שזה נכון בפרק של היום של Qiskit בכיתה נדבר על איך שהמשפט של Bell
הוכיח ש-Einstein
טעה ברוכים הבאים ל-Qiskit בכיתה בסדרה הזאת נשתמש ב-Qiskit כדי לחקור כמה מושגים בסיסיים שנלמדים בדרך כלל
בקורסים שקשורים למחשוב קוונטי לכל סרטון יתלווה גם מודול אינטראקטיבי
שמקושר בתיאור למטה אז בטוח תבדקו את זה בסרטון של המטבעות הקוונטיים דיברנו על איך שמדידה של
סופרפוזיציה קוונטית היא תהליך הסתברותי מטבעו כמו הטלת מטבע במובנים מסוימים אבל איך אנחנו יודעים
את זה יכול להיות שחלקיק קוונטי מסתיר בסתר תוצאה קבועה מראש של מדידה אבל אנחנו איכשהו לא מצליחים
לתפוס את המידע הזה בתיאוריה שלנו בימים הראשונים של מכניקת הקוונטים השאלה הזאת היתה נושא
לוויכוח סוער עם שני מחנות עיקריים במחנה אחד היה Einstein שהאמין שמכניקת הקוונטים לא שלמה
כלומר שחסרים בה כמה משתנים שנחוצים כדי לתאר מערכת באופן מלא Einstein חשב ש
המשתנים החבויים האלה אם ימצאו אותם יפתרו כמה מההיבטים לכאורה פרדוקסליים והסתברותיים
של מכניקת הקוונטים במחנה השני היה Max Bourne. Bourne טען
שהתיאור ההסתברותי שנותנת מכניקת הקוונטים הוא כל מה שהטבע מגדיר במילים אחרות זה
לא רק שאנחנו לא יודעים את מצב החלקיק לפני המדידה אלא שלחלקיק אין מצב מוגדר
לפני שמודדים אותו במשך עשורים רבים חשבו שהמחלוקת הזאת היא שאלה פילוסופית שאולי לעולם לא
תיפתר הרי כדי ללמוד משהו על מערכת אנחנו צריכים למדוד אותה איך אפשר בכלל ללמוד
משהו על טבעו של מצב לפני המדידה שלו אז ב-1964 הפיזיקאי
John Bell מצא דרך במאמר שלו Bell בחן את המתאמים הסטטיסטיים בין מדידות של זוג
חלקיקים שזורים אם לפני המדידה מצבי החלקיקים נקבעו על ידי משתנים חבויים לא ידועים
אז Bell מצא שלמתאמים שלהם יש גבול עליון מצד שני כשהוא חישב את
המתאמים שמכניקת הקוונטים חוזה הוא מצא שהם מפרים את הגבול הזה אז הוא מצא דרך פעם אחת
ולתמיד להבדיל בין הגישה של Einstein לגישה של Bourne כל מה שנשאר היה לבדוק באמת ניסויית
את המתאמים האלה עם חלקיקים אמיתיים כדי לראות אם הם מצייתים לסטטיסטיקה של משתנים חבויים או שהם
מפרים את הכלל הזה הבדיקות האלה בוצעו עם דיוק ותחכום הולכים וגדלים
לאורך השנים והם כמה מהניסויים המשמעותיים ביותר בפיזיקה המודרנית הם היו כל כך פורצי דרך ש
הם הזכו שלושה פיזיקאים בפרס נובל ב-2022 אבל בימינו כל אחד יכול לבצע
מבחן Bell כל מה שצריך זה קצת ידע ב-Qiskit וגישה למחשב קוונטי של IBM בסרטון הזה אני הולך
להדריך אתכם בלוגיקה של אי-השוויון של Bell ואז אראה לכם איך אפשר לבדוק את התחזיות של Bell על מחשב קוונטי של IBM
אי-השוויון של Bell כולל כמה מדידות שונות ושכבות של לוגיקה וזה יכול להיות
קצת מסובך לעקוב אבל נעבור על זה צעד אחרי צעד ובסוף זה יהיה שווה את זה אנחנו עומדים להראות
ששזירה קוונטית היא אמיתית ו-Einstein טעה זה לא משהו שהרבה אנשים יכולים להגיד שהם עשו אז הנה
מה ש-Bell הציע נגיד שיש לכם דרך לייצר הרבה עותקים של זוג שזור של חלקיקים פיזיקלית
הזוגות האלה יכולים להיווצר בתהליך דעיכה שבו חלקיק אחד מתפרק לשניים אם ראיתם את הסרטון על
ניסוי Stern-Gerlach אתם יודעים שלחלקיקים יכול להיות תנע זוויתי פנימי שנקרא
ספין נגיד שחלקיק אחד עם ספין אפס מתפרק לשני חלקיקים עם ספין 1/2
אז כל אחד מחלקיקי הספין 1/2 יכול להימדד כבעל ספין פלוס 1/2 או מינוס
1/2 שנקרא גם ספין למעלה או ספין למטה אבל מכיוון שהם התפרקו מחלקיק עם ספין אפס אז השניים חייבים להצטרף
לספין כולל של אפס גם כן אז אם אחד נמדד למעלה השני חייב להיות
למטה ולהיפך החלקיקים האלה יוצרים זוג שזור שנראה ככה
אז אם אחד נמדד למעלה השני למטה ולהיפך נגיד שחלקיק אחד עף שמאלה או
בכיוון מינוס X שם חוקר שנקרא לו Lucas מודד את
הספין שלו ואז חלקיק שני עף באותו אופן ימינה
שם חוקרת אחרת Rihanna יכולה למדוד את הספין הזה Lucas ו-Rihanna יכולים באופן עצמאי
לסובב את מכשירי המדידה שלהם כדי לבחור למדוד את הספין של החלקיקים שלהם לאורך כל כיוון
מאונך לכיוון התנועה של החלקיק אם נשלח הרבה עותקים של המצב השזור ל-Lucas
ול-Rihanna הם יכולים לאסוף סטטיסטיקת מדידות אם הם תמיד מודדים לאורך אותו ציר הסטטיסטיקה לא תהיה
מעניינת במיוחד כל פעם שאחד מודד ספין למעלה השני מודד ספין למטה וכל פעם שאחד מודד ספין
קדימה השני מודד ספין אחורה וכן הלאה אבל אם שני החוקרים מודדים לאורך צירים שונים אולי נמצא
משהו יותר מעניין בואו ניתן ל-Lucas ול-Rihanna שלושה צירים שלאורכם
למדוד נקרא לצירים האלה a, b ו-c והם מופרדים כל אחד ב-
120 מעלות השאלה שנשאל בניסוי הזה היא אם Lucas ו-Rihanna חופשיים למדוד לאורך כל אחד משלושת
הצירים כמה פעמים השניים יקבלו את אותו סימן ברור שאם Lucas ו-Rihanna במקרה מודדים לאורך אותו ציר
נגיד ציר a הם לעולם לא יכולים לקבל את אותו סימן כי החלקיקים חייבים להצטרף לספין אפס אבל כשהם בוחרים
צירים שונים איך המדידות שלהם יהיו מתואמות אם בכלל לפי Einstein התיאור הקוונטי
המכני הזה של מצב החלקיק לא שלם הוא חשב שחייבים להיות משתנים חבויים ש
קובעים מראש את התוצאה של כל מדידות הספין האפשריות כי בלי זה חלקיקים שזורים היו צריכים
איכשהו לתקשר את תוצאת המדידה שלהם זה לזה באופן מיידי אם אחד נמדד
למעלה פה הרחק השני חייב מיידית לדעת להיות למטה
פה המשתנים החבויים האלה יכולים להיות כל קבוצת הוראות מסובכת לתוצאות ניסויים אבל העניין הוא
שמצב הספין של כל חלקיק בנפרד נקבע מראש אז לא צריך תקשורת
ניסויית זה אומר שמדידות שעושה Lucas לא ישפיעו על החלקיק של Rihanna ולהיפך
זה יכול לשים כמה מגבלות על כמה שתי המדידות יכולות להיות מתואמות אבל לפי Bourne המצב
psi הוא כל מה שאפשר להגיד על זוג החלקיקים לפני המדידה אז מדידה של חלקיק אחד
משפיעה על תוצאת המדידה של השני לזה עשויות להיות השלכות שונות על המתאמים בין מדידות בואו נראה איך כל
תיאוריה משפיעה על המתאמים האלה בגישת המשתנים החבויים יש קבוצת הוראות סודית לפני
המדידה שכבר קובעת מה Lucas ימדוד לאורך כל אחד משלושת הצירים למשל ההוראות
האלה יכולות להיות חיובי אם Lucas מודד לאורך ציר a
חיובי אם הוא מודד לאורך b ושלילי אם הוא מודד לאורך c אפשר
לכתוב את זה כפלוס a פלוס b ומינוס c ואז החלקיק של Rihanna
יצטרך להיות עם המשתנים מינוס a מינוס b ופלוס c כדי לוודא שהספין הכולל
לאורך כל כיוון בודד הוא אפס
יש שמונה קבוצות של הוראות אפשריות שעונות על אילוץ ספין אפס אז כל פעם שזוג חדש של
חלקיקים נשלח ל-Lucas ול-Rihanna הוא יכול להכיל כל אחת משמונה קבוצות ההוראות האלה אז עכשיו אנחנו רוצים
לחשב בהנחה שהחלקיקים מכילים אחת מקבוצות ההוראות הסודיות שבטבלה ו
בהנחה ש-Lucas ו-Rihanna כל אחד בוחר באופן עצמאי לאורך איזה משלושת הצירים למדוד מה
ההסתברות ששניהם ימדדו את אותו סימן אם ההוראות הן אלה שבשורות 1 או
8 אז ברור שההסתברות הזאת היא אפס כי לשני החלקיקים יהיו סימנים הפוכים ללא קשר לצירי
המדידה שלהם אבל מה עם ההוראות בשורה שתיים הם ימדדו את אותם סימנים אם
Rihanna מודדת לאורך c ו-Lucas מודד לאורך a או b או אם Lucas
מודד לאורך c ו-Rihanna מודדת לאורך a או b אז זה ארבע מתוך תשע של
שילובי המדידה האפשריים שייתנו ל-Lucas ול-Rihanna את אותו סימן אם נעשה את זה עבור
כל קבוצת הוראות תראו ששורות 3 עד 7 גם נותנות הסתברות של 4/9 זה אומר שאם
Einstein צודק ומשתנים חבויים כאלה קובעים מראש את תוצאות המדידות אין שום דרך ש-Lucas
ו-Rihanna ימדדו את אותו סימן בהסתברות גדולה מ-4/9 זהו אי-השוויון של Bell P קטן או שווה
ל-4/9 וכפי שנראה חלקיקים שזורים מפרים את זה אז כדי
לראות מה מכניקת הקוונטים חוזה נגיד ש-Lucas מודד לאורך a שני דברים יכולים לקרות או שהוא מודד ספין למעלה אז
Rihanna תמדוד ספין למטה לאורך a או שהוא מודד ספין למטה ו-Rihanna תמדוד ספין למעלה לאורך a אבל אנחנו
רוצים את ההסתברות ש-Rihanna תמדוד את אותו סימן כמו Lucas לאורך כל ציר שהיא בוחרת לא רק a אם
היא מודדת לאורך b או c זה נהיה קצת מסובך מסתבר ש
אם יודעים מה Rihanna תמדוד ב-100% ודאות לאורך כיוון אחד אז אפשר לחשב את ההסתברויות
שהיא תמדוד למעלה או למטה לאורך כל ציר אחר עם קצת גיאומטריה
אם המצב שלך תמיד מודד ספין למעלה לאורך ציר אחד אז ההסתברות למדוד ספין למעלה לאורך ציר אחר
תהיה שווה לריבוע של הקוסינוס של חצי הזווית בין שני הצירים זה קצת מסובך אבל
אראה לכם למה הכוונה אם Lucas מודד ספין למעלה לאורך a אנחנו יודעים ב-100% ודאות ש-Rihanna תמדוד
ספין למטה אם היא מודדת לאורך a אז אפשר לייצג את זה עם וקטור
ככה במקרה הזה הזוויות בין הוקטור הזה לבין שני צירי המדידה האחרים b ו-c הן שתיהן
60 מעלות אז חצי מזה זה 30 מעלות וקוסינוס של
30 מוצג כאן קוסינוס בריבוע של
30 מעלות שווה 3/4 עכשיו מה אם Lucas מודד ספין למטה
לאורך a אנחנו יודעים ש-Rihanna תמדוד ספין למעלה לאורך a אז אפשר לצייר וקטור אחר כאן עכשיו
הוקטור הזה שמייצג את הידיעה הזאת הוא 120 מעלות מכל אחד משני הצירים האחרים b
ו-c אז אפשר לעשות את אותו טריק גיאומטרי אבל הפעם נקבל קוסינוס של
60 מעלות אז קוסינוס בריבוע של
60 מעלות שווה 1/4 מכיוון ש-Lucas באותה מידה עשוי
למדוד ספין למעלה וספין למטה לאורך a אנחנו צריכים לעשות ממוצע של שתי ההסתברויות של Rihanna ונקבל הסתברות סופית
ש-Rihanna תמדוד את אותו סימן כמו Lucas של 1/2 אז P
שווה ל-1/2 זה גדול מ-4/9 אז אי-השוויון של Bell מופר
זה אומר שכל עוד חוקי מכניקת הקוונטים מתקיימים משתנים חבויים הם בלתי אפשריים עכשיו אפשר להשתמש ב-Qiskit ובמחשב
קוונטי של IBM כדי לבדוק את אי-השוויון של Bell עם מדידות קוונטיות אמיתיות אפשר למפות את מצבי ספין למעלה ו
ספין למטה של החלקיקים של Lucas ו-Rihanna למצבי אפס ואחד של ה-qubit במחשב הקוונטי ניקח
שני qubit אחד לייצג את החלקיק של Lucas ואחד של Rihanna ונשזור אותם עם ה-circuit הקוונטי הזה
אז שני ה-qubit מיוצגים על ידי שני החוטים q0 ו-q1 והשילוב הזה
של X, Hadamard ו-gate C-NOT יצרו את אותו מצב שזור שהיה בין החלקיקים של Lucas ו-Rihanna עכשיו אנחנו
צריכים למדוד כל qubit נגדיר את המדידה של Lucas לאורך a שנגיד שזה ציר Z ואז המדידה של Rihanna
יכולה להיות לאורך a, b או c אז נצטרך שלושה circuit נפרדים לכל אחד משלושת המקרים אבל בסרטון
הזה נעשה רק אחד אפשר ללכת למודול שמקושר בתיאור לדבר המלא אם Rihanna מודדת לאורך
b אז ה-circuit שלנו נראה ככה כש-RY הוא סיבוב של 120 מעלות כדי לשנות
את ציר המדידה של Rihanna אפשר להשתמש ב-Qiskit Primitive Sampler כדי להריץ את הניסוי הזה הרבה פעמים ולאסוף
סטטיסטיקה מהמדידות שני העמודות 0 0 ו-1 1 מייצגות את הפעמים ש-Lucas ו-
Rihanna מדדו את אותו סימן שזה מה שאנחנו מחפשים אז ההסתברות שלשני החלקיקים יהיה
אותו סימן היא כמעט 1/2 וזה מפר את אי-השוויון של Bell זה אומר
ששני החלקיקים שזורים כל אחד מהם איכשהו יודע מיידית את תוצאות
המדידה של השני עדיין יש קצת מחלוקת לגבי איך בדיוק לפרש את השזירה
הזאת ומה קורה כשמודדים מצב שזור אבל השאלות האלה הן יותר פילוסופיות
התיאוריה היא די בלתי ניתנת להכחשה בשלב הזה שזירה קוונטית היא בהחלט אמיתית ואנחנו יודעים את זה בזכות Bell אי-
השוויון שלו והפיזיקאים הרבים שביצעו ניסויים כדי לבדוק את זה אם אתם רוצים להיספר בין אותם
פיזיקאים ולבצע מבחן Bell משלכם עם מחשב קוונטי בטוח תלכו למודול אי-השוויון של Bell
שמקושר בתיאור תודה שצפיתם ונתראה בפעם הבאה